you're my friend
you're you're a charming dynamic and i'm
this isn't i'm not blowing smoke this is
just who you are you're a charming
dynamic magnetic guy
personality
essence and energy
and as much as you want to repel
the world or girls or your family or
whatever
like a moth to a flame
people are drawn to that energy to that
light
and someday a girl if that's what you're
trying to block out
a girl will be drawn to that light very
powerfully maybe the way you were yeah
and you will sense that girl's energy
she will come into the light and you
won't be able to resist that energy you
you will let her
like take a lot of handle though like
the candle you talked about with that
little mechanism that it's inside all
right i'm just not going to open that
thing
right that thing is going to be locked i
say you will though because she
her energy will cause that door to
slowly open right what if i have a
different another what's under two
different walls i think i'm blocking
energy as well i think everyone says
that but i think there's always a person
comes along that knows how to melt the
ice but i agree i don't know
and thank it's a beautiful thing it's
not a beautiful thing and it horrifies
me no it's great because a lot of the
times when you don't want to fall in
love and you put up those walls and
paper up the windows is exactly when
that
person that's strong enough to get there
i can't i can't no
you're about to say note that just i
just have to refute you okay please
refute i cannot wait
i can't because i i've thought about
this
people say this you're not the only
macho man
that said this oh oh oh he's on butter
now
yeah you're gonna say matcha
yeah every action is all equal and
opposite
that was ultra [ __ ] much
button back up thanks um well you gotta
have your fly open i mean it's okay but
i
i everyone people have guys have said
this to me right because i've i've said
this privately to be like i have no
interest at all i no longer no more
right right and i can't wait five years
from now
right i'll run into you again harlow
right at the club in the back
and i'm going to look at you and i go
it's been five years
not one person yeah but you believe me
then i will but it could be the next day
after you say that that it has been 20
years from now
then 20 21 years after that
someone will get a never-ending [ __ ]
thing it's like all those circus mirrors
you're a human man can i ask you a
question go ahead how fun was it though
when we first met and fell in love why
would you because i don't i know
that was bobby regardless how painful
this ended we had a blast for 10 years
yeah we built this amazing thing
together for 10 years why would you why
would you deny yourself the opportunity
to create a new chapter in your life
because i now have seen all three of the
star wars movies
and that's the thing right
the first one the one that jj abrams won
was pretty good
and i'm like this is the relationship
right and then the second one
right ah not great third one
even you know so you see the whole
series
right
so i'm cool what's the first one called
the force awakens yeah yeah i mean in
the beginning
i i love the force awakens yeah yeah i
mean
i do right but i've seen the return of
the jedi the last jedi and the last jedi
so that's my point i don't want to see
all of them
if there were all the force awakens
right
but then you'd have to leave
two years in
and i don't want to do that i did that
before you every relationship i talked
to sarah there today my you know sarah
highland the ex right and i go two years
i that was it but kalila was 10 years
all right i saw the full movie
and um i just want to go through that
again
but what if it doesn't end the same way
but it will
why do you say that what if it's a
completely different storyline not even
the star wars what if it's because i
started i'll be i'll give you an example
you love every single episode of next
gen it's so many episodes no not
everything's
i went to rite aid last night and i ate
medieval medieval madness the ice cream
i don't know right
i've tried every rite aid flavor
right and i've had i've had medieval
madness before i don't like it have you
had birthday cake remix i did great
right but sometimes i'll get that
sometimes i get the chocolate chip
pistachio that's how i'm like with [ __ ]
okay all right so if you had the uh
green and brown blob on the floor in
aisle six
[Laughter]
my point is is that you know i just you
know
there's i think
by just being a male
maybe i want variety
oh that's fine maybe i think all males
are like that i think some of them
get locked in and they have these
dutiful things and they have they're
part of you know you're an institution
that you're married you're part of this
thing and this agreement but i don't
think that's instinctually
what you want to do i think george you
have a mayor you have another kick on
the way congratulations i love i think
your first kid is beautiful i haven't
met the second one yet but my point is
is that um i'm sure it's great but um
might be a little silly but um
yeah but my point is is that i'm pretty
sure
you know i mean i hope your wife is not
listening but during the live set that
one night that we did the live there
might be some girls there that you
probably were eyeing like i wish in a
different universe that i could plow
you know what i mean that word again
yeah
go ahead you're you're saying you're
open to fooling around with girls you're
just saying you're not going to get in
deep with a girl is what you're saying
that's what i meant you're not going to
fall in love deep
a deep
thing i still think you're right yeah
that's the thing you you doing all this
talking but i'm telling you bro you have
no control when that one girl walks
through the door
and kicks your walls down
you're helpless
has that happened to you yeah okay oh
yeah that's all i want to know i went
over i lived in germany for a while when
uh this was in uh the late
the mid-80s
i lived in germany i did and i just gone
through a huge breakup and i went over
to germany i said man i just said
everything you just said
and i grew i'd never had a beard i grew
a beard out to try and look gruff and
look look like unkept and everything i
could do to keep girls away and i had
i'd turn all the radar off i wasn't like
you know what do you mean you dim down
the the the energy vibe for women
and uh i was working in computer
animation and there was this guy who was
teaching us this this
guy who worked at the company i was at
and the [ __ ]
every night his girlfriend would come
and pick him up and she was
stunning she was like a young fade done
away with long blonde hair german like
just unbelievable
i had nothing i didn't want anything to
do with her we're all at a party one
night and i was just at the party
and
i'd been around her for a few months and
i was at the party and you ever have
that feeling when someone's looking at
you and you can just feel it yeah and
i'm at the party and i'm just going what
the [ __ ] is going on
i could feel it and i look and all of a
sudden i looked across the room
and this girl was just staring at me
like carrie's mother
it was just like this look
that was like i love you and i just flew
across the room and i go what what are
you doing
and it was on i thought she was dating
some other guy she was
whoa it just she found me the two moths
flew into the light and it was
it was i didn't want anything to do with
it especially i was overseas i didn't
want to find a girlfriend over in
germany yeah emotional yeah it was it
was like boom how long did you see her
for
i was there for about a year and a half
and the final the final night we were
together we had to drive up to uh
hamburg for a film festival and it was
the most romantic setting you've ever
seen so they were at this it was night
time
outdoor film festival and in this water
fountain
in hamburg they set up this huge screen
like must have been 80 feet across 60
feet high gigantic
and an old black and white
elizabeth taylor richard burton movie
was playing
and we're standing there kind of up
against the wall and and it was it was
just there in the background and it was
me and her and i said i said baby i'm
going to america i'm i'm moving to
hollywood in two days
and i said i gotta know right now do you
love
me and
she said i love i love you and i said
well one of us has to move
me or you like
and it was just it was so incredible
this this movie playing in the
background you could hear the voices and
you could see it and they were like you
know 90 feet high these elizabeth taylor
was just
but it was exactly what you're saying
like i don't know how big there is
she's nice
godzilla
but it was it was anyways my point is i
i tried what you tried and and at some
point
someone just gets through the barrier
i just learned from you just now
when someone's staring at me leave
but that's what i mean you can't i will
you're it's like a rafter beam no
once i get that to me
those are pain eyes
that's a different eyes that's a
different stare the love stare is
to
21 years guy
guy love you love you yeah see you at
carl's jr in half an hour curly fries
it's gonna happen all right if you say
so but be happy about it about what
about finding that next person everyone
here it's a beautiful thing
ours is so recent
yeah it's a month and we still live
together sleep on the same bed we watch
things we've been watching the boys yeah
but i've reconciled with the fact that
like with what you're saying it's like
at some point i want to move on with my
life you know you'll have the same thing
and even though i feel really grim about
it now i do believe that i will have
another chance at another story he's
both of you and that's the beauty of
life my story is done short story no i
remember my essay when my grandmother my
grandmother was very religious she she
she was her husband died i think he was
in his 70s my grandfather died right at
his desk she went to pick him up every
day one day she went
she went in he was face down on his desk
is this real this is real wow my
grandfather neil o'donnell and
she was very religious and she said i
will never see be with another man neil
was my whole life and we all believed it
how old was she at the time oh she had
to be in her 70s wow and we were like oh
yeah but
nanny will never ever like we and two
and a half years later she had a
boyfriend named clyde who had a little
chihuahua
and we couldn't believe it and and i was
i was sort of sad but i was like man
that's life it just you can't shut it
off it's just love just keeps coming
sometimes it takes years or months or
weeks but
it'll find a kid
and if it doesn't i will i will
i will love you
not sexually but we'll go camping
you know you do burning man right yeah
yeah i thought the deal was you were
gonna take him to his first burning man
oh the last time right do you want to go
yeah
last time you were here three years ago
we talked about you never invited me one
[ __ ] time prove it hit they shut it
down have you been there is everything
still going it's